welcome back the stimulus standoff
continues nancy pelosi still playing
hardball with the white house despite
pressure from members in her own party
to cut a deal
the speaker set a 48-hour deadline for
the trump administration to agree on the
terms
we want to have an agreement we can come
to negotiation
and we can do it now what's the
difference a few days
except that we could have it before the
election which we wanted as soon as
possible and i certainly want it because
i don't want to have to be sweeping up
after this
dumpings of this elephant as we go into
a new presidency
in a few short months meanwhile the
senate taking a different approach
and is set to vote this week on a pair
of stimulus bills that would extend the
paycheck protection program and expand
unemployment benefits all right so greg
eight million americans have slipped
into poverty because of this pandemic
and the economic ramifications
what is pelosi doing she's doing what
she always does she plays politics and
the fact is
we are always on our own right when it
comes down to politics they don't really
care especially if that's their survival
this is why we need term limits because
term limits always make
politicians care less about winning yeah
and more about the people around them
and of course we will never have term
limits so what am i talking about i'm
looking forward
to whatever innovation there is that
comes out of this because
the politics is so depressing but you
know we're already getting telemedicine
i would like to see innovation when it
comes to school
uh schools and health and like like the
space program
right you know the things that we got
from the space program we must be
getting something
well that's the question zoom don't tell
jeffrey
so what is the benefit of this strategy
though as millions of americans are
suffering what if any is the benefit
well i as i said last week i actually am
very frightened for
a lot of people millions of people like
if you look at the job losses
from february to may for example in
accommodation and food services 38
percent
arts entertainment and recreation 47
mining and logging down 10 i could go on
i have a whole list here
and i think that the key point for the
president is that i actually think this
deal and getting this deal done
would help him the most going into this
debate on thursday night
because he's the deal maker he's the one
that can tell the senate who wants to do
500 billion dollars and
she wants to do two trillion dollars
fine he could he could bring them
together and put them in the room it is
the right thing to do for the country
it is imperative that they get it done
sooner than later because every day that
you wait means that there's another it's
a lag time
and you're going to get into the winter
and people that are on now on finding
themselves on food stamps or having to
go to the food bank
because all they want to do is work but
we're not helping them that is
unconscionable
and i think that he's the one that could
actually be the difference maker here if
he wants to be
but he's got to get on the phone with
these republicans and say i am telling
you
this is what i want this is my priority
if he doesn't do that i think a lot of
them are going to say
we're not going to play nancy pelosi's
game but here's the thing you just
answered your own question it says
that if he gets a deal it's going to
help him so they're not going to give
him a deal
that's just the way it is i think that
if you hear her she's realizing that she
needs a deal too
i don't know at this point i think she
wants to delay the deal until after the
election and wait and see if joe biden
wins then she can give the extra
trillion to the democrat governors of
the blue states and help bail them out
so they can buy votes
if she does the deal now it helps trump
and the american people
and that's not what she wants she's not
going to be able to spend that as a
victory for democrats but
we brought so much peop so many people
out of poverty
five million people were brought out of
poverty in the first three years
of the administration that's a record
they had it down to 10.5 percent
poverty rate another record and to hear
about more millions of people going into
poverty because they want to play
politics with us
it's sad and they're actually hurting
themselves because blue states
have twice as high of a jobless rate
than red states
so they're only doing this to hurt
themselves if you look at it
to jesse's point pelosi's office
released a statement saying she thinks
there will be a deal by the election
so why how is this a defensible strategy
in the interim by getting nothing done
if she knows they're going to reach a
deal soon why not reach it now so people
can get their help
it's not pelosi it's trump i mean
everybody said if trump is the deal
maker that's his reputation
and trump's not willing to make a deal
what we know is that the house has twice
passed this kind of package and trump
initially said
it's not enough then he cut off the
talks emily he cut him off he said no
more
so i mean if trump wants to make a deal
he should go to senator mcconnell the
majority leader in the senate
and say let's make a deal mcconnell is
the one who stayed
just frozen in terms of the house action
he's now playing doing a dog and pony
show
saying oh well i'm gonna pass this
skinny bill as they call it a little
bill
but all that will do they'll do more
harm than good why
because it allow him to say i gave you
something that's enough no more
when in fact everyone the federal
reserve chair president trump says we
need more so where's president trump why
does he act like a president
and make a deal anybody can make a deal
one you want a good deal
all right